these truck drivers are used to
crisscrossing china driving hundreds of
kilometers every day
but a nationwide shortage of diesel fuel
has changed that
i'm scared to leave beijing and drive
long distances some petrol stations have
run out of diesel filling machines are
closed two days ago i drove south to
hubei province and many petrol stations
didn't have any the shortage has been
accompanied by a sharp rise in prices
since january the cost of diesel here
has increased by about 30 percent at
this petrol station customers are
limited to buying just 200 liters of
diesel fuel but outside the capital the
supply problem is much worse with some
truck drivers having to wait days to
refuel
there have been long lines of vehicles
at petrol stations in china's southern
and eastern provinces due to rationing
many drivers say they can only refuel
for one day's journey which means
cross-country deliveries are taking
longer to arrive
china is in the middle of a power crisis
that has triggered blackouts in many
cities shortages of coal and natural gas
have led to a surge in diesel
consumption factories and businesses
have turned to diesel-powered generators
to maintain operations draining supply
the second reason is probably because a
lot of diesel is being re-routed to the
agriculture sector during this harvest
season
to basically support a green drying and
and to prepare for uh for planting
winter crops
and on the on the supply side basically
the
the the domestic supply for diesel has
been going down because china has been
exporting a lot more diesel
to the restaurant to the rest of the
world
some estimate china's diesel stockpiles
to be at their lowest level in at least
a year
environmental crackdowns on crude oil
production in some regions have worsened
the shortage
the government has asked chinese
refineries to increase production and
imports but this won't be enough to
contain the shortfall
experts warn that scarcity of diesel is
likely to last for months and could
worsen existing problems in the global
supply chain katrina u al jazeera
beijing